my next guest uh calling in right now
his new book is available wherever books
are sold
uncomfortable conversations with a black
man emmanuel acho
here on the rich eisen show how are you
sir rich how are you my man
life is good life is busy but good it is
busy for you
congratulations on that obviously you're
also uh with on speak for yourself
on fox sports you've you've made quite a
name
and uh uh a brand for yourself emanuel
uh
how did you get this thing started it is
not easy to come off the nfl gridiron
and try to make a career out of yourself
when you don't have maybe a
a bust or a yellow jacket in your future
how'd you do this how did you start
that is very very true a man i think
it's a matter of leaning into your skill
set it's like with the nfl
rich i said i might not be the fastest i
might not be the strongest
but i will make it a point to always be
the smartest and now
speaking for a living on television and
racial reconciliation
i just said let me lean into my craft
where is the need
in this life and let me try to fill it
on sports the need it's entertainment
it's opinions it's analysis
but rich when you're talking about
racial reconciliation the need currently
in this country is understanding it's
empathy
it's it's it's white brothers and
sisters understanding black brothers and
sisters i realized there was a need
so i wrote the book to kind of step in
the gap and fill phyllis
and you spoke to commissioner roger
goodell in your digital series
um for uncomfortable conversations with
a black man that was a
i was a two-parter um how did you find
that conversation
emanuel great great question so i get a
call from a no caller id number
rich i've gotten three no caller id
number calls the first matthew
mcconaughey
the second oprah winfrey and the third
being commissioner roger goodell and
roger goodell he called me and he said
emmanuel i saw one of your episodes
it was an adoption episode um a white
parents adopted this sweet black
the sweet black girl named story and her
brother named amos
and he said it tugged on my heart
because my dad was a u.s senator he
wanted to adopt
a young black girl from nigeria but
couldn't because of his role within the
u.s government
he said that episode moved me i want to
have a conversation with you
and while him and i talked he he simply
said that you know what i i've
opened up my mind and realized i got
some things wrong
over the over the years you know i
didn't really understand
kaepernick's message at first i i didn't
understand what my players were talking
about which he said
when you hear people saying something
you get an
idea of it but it's not until you go see
it for yourself
that you feel it and so the conversation
with
commissioner roger goodell it was
premised around
trying to bridge the divide between
ownership which is 95 percent white
and players which are 75 percent black
he wanted to also
try what he could to mend the divide
within the nfl
so what do you make of the the rule
that uh nfl ownership just uh
undertook uh involving diversity hiring
in the nfl
and encouraging it uh with with draft
choices what
do you think of this emanuel uh that's a
very complex question i do think that
people need a motivation to diversify
i think that's in life my coach will
muschamp head coach of south carolina he
was my defensive coordinator
at the university of texas when we were
playing in the national championship
he told me richie said don't be like
water
water takes the easiest route if you
pour water on the ground it's going to
take the path of least resistance as it
travels
in the same manner we do as people see
people think the nfl is a meritocracy
and it's not it's based upon cronyism
and nepotism cronyism you hire your
friends and nepotism you hire your
family
and so if the nfl has historically been
predominantly
white owners and white coaches and
they're hiring their friends and their
family
then there will be no diversity but what
we know about diversity
in the nfl and out of the nfl it
increases competition risk let me give
you this anecdote for your listeners i'm
sure you already know it
2003 the nfl implements the rooney rule
you have to interview a minority
candidate if you have a head coaching
vacancy
by 2004 a man by the name of lovey smith
the black man was hired
in 2007 for the first time in nfl
history
two black head coaches meet in the super
bowl rich statistically speaking there
was less than a four percent chance that
that would happen
so what we found out was this rooney
rule it actually
advanced the level of play in a game in
which we all
love and i am all about advancing the
level of play in a game in which i
played with
and a game in which i love if the
incentivization is necessary to do that
then so be it emmanuel acho the author
of uncomfortable conversations with a
black man is this essentially just the
book version of the video series that
we've been
all taken in so no it's i actually try
to
expand on so many things so each chapter
starts with a real question from a real
um email that i received the video
series has over 70 million views rich so
you can imagine i've gotten a lot of
questions
so one first chapter might be like okay
emanuel what should i say
black or african american and i'll
expound on that okay emmanuel
how come hip-hop artists still use the
n-word in
songs but i as a white person can't say
that
okay emmanuel what's this concept of
white privilege
okay emmanuel but what about you know
the black family struggle that we see
okay emmanuel how come black people
haven't been able to recover even though
slavery was hundreds of years ago
so rich i think the spoken word has
sizzle but the written word has
substance i wanted to give people a
figurative baton
to pass down and change uh
racial reconciliation from generation to
generation so
it's more expanding on real questions
from real people
because i understand based on proximity
and where people grow up
you might not have had these
conversations with black people you
might not have had
been friends with black people so i said
consider this book the safe space to
learn and to grow
so uh what answer some of those
questions you just
asked if you don't mind no
no i mean i don't want to people will
definitely still get your book here but
you want to you want to hit a couple of
them yeah i think
the first one is this when i was talking
to oprah at first rich
we were going back and forth on email a
couple facetime calls and i said oprah
what do you want me to call you
you want me to call you oprah you want
me to call you oh you want me to call
you your majesty
i'm like why do you want me to call you
and rich he said oprah is fine i say
that because
if you don't know what to call somebody
you can't say you're really friends
when people say emmanuel akko i'm like
acho no emmanuel ocho no no it's ocho if
you can't pronounce my name you can't
say we're friends
so when you ask is it black or african
american
i say black is safer because black is
just simply an
adjective describing one's skin color
like white
is i think that black is an adjective
not a noun black describes people
not those blacks over there personally
that's my preference i also think that
because of slavery
um black people's heritage was stripped
from them during the course of slavery
their african-american heritage
so some of them don't identify with that
heritage so
that's the primary one that i actually
open up the book with
called the name game um and and we talk
about privilege and so many other things
but without expanding into too much
detail
um you got to know what to call somebody
rich
if you're really going to be friends so
um
what do you say emmanuel ocho here on
the rich hasn't show uh how do you
respond to the stick to sports stuff
i'm sure you get it a lot and you know
you work for fox
um on the news side that's all that's
all they say to
um uh african-american athletes who
speak up
uh on subject matters that um some of
the
opinionators on fox news don't like how
do you respond to that
emmanuel i believe that to whom much has
given much is required rich
to whom much has given much is required
athletes have been given a lot
so it's my personal belief that a lot is
required of
us i also believe this what ben franklin
said justice will not be served until
those who are unaffected
are as outraged as those who are
affected um for the most part
athletes high profile figures you are
unaffected by a lot of what occurs in
society
while you are playing said sport you're
protected on the field you have private
security private charter buses
private planes you are unaffected
but justice won't be served until those
that are unaffected are as outraged as
those that
are affected so if those that are
unaffected
athletes um um but potentially white men
in a society that has often protected
white men if they are not as outraged
about
injustice of all kinds as those that are
affected
then rich will never see justice so that
is my response when someone says stick
to sports
so uh in a couple minutes that we have
left here emanuel let's let's get to
sports um
who's your mvp halfway through the
season in the nfl
it's got to be it's got to be patrick
mahomes right now man
it was russell wilson he was running
away with it but the problem is
this whole let rust cook mantra he's
burned a couple meals rich
he's burned a couple meals when we were
letting him cook patrick mahomes with
what only one interception to i believe
25 touchdowns at this point
he's my number one aaron rodgers
currently my number two i believe 24
touchdowns to two
interceptions um and then russell wilson
is number three if russ can
get back on track then i think russell
wilson can win it a guy who's never had
an
mvp vote but the fact of the matter is
his russell wilson has thrown as many
interceptions in his last eight games
as aaron rodgers has thrown in his last
40 games just to put that in context
that stuff matters so uh what did you
make
um i'm assuming you spoke about it on
your show if you didn't all good
it's it's no offense to the fact that it
was said here lamar jackson
talking about the defense uh
occasionally calling out the plays
before
he snaps it on his own yeah it's funny
i just got off a production call we will
be talking about that today as we were
dark yesterday
um i was surprised that lamar jackson
said it when you're playing in the nfl
again i told you i was never the biggest
the fastest but i
pride myself in being the smartest as a
defender
they can only run so many plays on
offense and the ravens offense is not
that
complex it is very efficient but it's
not very complex
they'll come out in about eight
different formations and out of those
eight different formations they may have
three plays
based on each formation so it's simply
process of elimination rich
they come out there in a certain
formation you know they can only run
three to five
things so i was really just taking them
back that lamar jackson actually said
that
out loud it was the first time i
questioned
kind of lamar jackson's understanding of
of defensive football that statement
that he made i was just like huh that's
interesting that he would say that
well maybe he's just uh uh you know
i i know it's not his first rodeo an
impressionable young kid is just being
honest with
in a conversation right i mean i i'll
give you the floor a little bit more
here
why is it an indictment of of lamar's
abilities is it because he's not
checking out himself out of something
that he knows that's already been
sniffed out by the defense is that where
you're going is that what you're aiming
at
no and i wouldn't even necessarily say
that it's an indictment of his ability
what i would say
is for the most part you know that
defenses can get a
jump on what you're doing now like like
his offensive coordinator greg roman
said
half the time a defense is guessing but
usually on
offense you're looking for a giveaway
rich let me let me let you in on a
little on a little bit of football and
if i'm a linebacker i'm looking at my
the offensive lineman i'll start at the
offensive tackle
at first i'm going to look for him is he
going to tell me if it's pass or run
then i'll look at the offensive guard
for those listening that aren't super in
depth of football that's the guy next to
the center
is he a foot further back from the
center because if so
he's probably going to pull if he's
going to pull i know that a
power run is coming so i when when i say
that i say that to say
lamar you know defenses are doing that
you just have to figure out who's the
giveaway on offense
there's always one because there are 11
offensive players
so it's not an indictment on lamar i
just
was surprised that he said it as opposed
to just going and privately handling it
emmanuel acho here on the rich eisen
show and then what did you make
of last night's game uh how significant
a win is that for the colts and
how deep you think this team can go
emmanuel i really man i wish
rich that the colts would have really
just gone out there and
like handed it to him here's what i mean
by that the titans
what they had a blocked punt and they
had a muff punt
and they had a missed field goal now
nobody cares about special teams until
special teams cost you a game and i was
a special teams player that's how i made
it in the nfl
so i do not undermine special teams but
when i look at the cults i'm still
trying to figure out what i can learn
from them
i believe they've beaten without looking
at it i believe they've beaten the
jaguars
i think they've beaten the jets i think
they've beaten a bunch of bad teams so
the titans win was really to me their
first
big win outside of beating the bears and
nick foles first start
i am still not sure what to make of the
colts they're offense
it doesn't scare me their defense is
stout
but is their defense really stout or
have they just not faced an offensive
jug or not
this nfl season is weird to me there's
still so
many ambiguities it is weird i can't
figure it out right now
although i just think the chiefs are the
best and and that saints went over the
bucks was
might might truly be the watershed
moment for that team i i
uh that that reeked of okay the saints
are now
fully constituted they've swept the team
that's closest to taking a home playoff
game away from them
uh in division that that had that
feeling to it last sunday
to me yep absolutely that that was a
game think about this rich
the bucks have outscored the rest of
their opponents by 96 points
and they have been outscored by the
saints i think by about
55 points something along those lines or
46 points rather
the saints really put a choke hold on
that division
the bucks were were sprinting into that
game
the saints were limping into that game
and when they got on the field at the
same time the saints handed it to him i
don't know how you can be the best team
in the nfc
if you're not the best team in your
division so kudos to the saints for
reminding everybody
who really runs that nfc south hey
emmanuel congrats on everything that's
gone on in your career i hope this is
the first of many times that we get to
talk
um if you do have you know continue to
have the ear of oprah
tell would you mind passing along to her
a a book idea i have called comfortable
conversations with a jewish man
you know a comfortable conversation with
the jewish man we could talk about
you know soup uh portions you know
um sandy kofax you know yeah
long goodbyes um again i'm just i'm just
going on i'm going on in my head
uh you know with what the chapters would
be i guess i could discuss that with you
offline just just throw that oprah's way
will you please
done and done rich good to be with you
man congrats for the congrats again on
the book the digital series your gig
with fox sports let's uh let's keep
talking
yes sir i'd say how do your brother was
on the other day too ah
yes he was it was great to challenge you
say hey okay you got it all the achos
here on the rich eisen show
that was a manual check out
uncomfortable conversations with a black
man available
now or ever books are sold hey you
watched all the way to the end thanks
for that
watch more right here